what is his political legacy going to be
well let me just start let's love like
it for our for the younger members of
our audience will do a little history
lesson that Barack Obama call very
interesting in the context of the 2008
presidential campaign as you and I
reported in the book that we wrote about
that game change very important moment
in Barack Obama's ascent was the moment
when Harry Reid in 2006 Obama still a
very young you only had been in the
Senate from out a year and a half Harry
Reid calls him up to Capitol Hill and
sits down and says you should run for
president it was a very big moment that
gave a sense to Obama that there are
democratic establishment that everyone
assumed was all behind Hillary Clinton
was in fact looking for an alternative
and it was one of the first moments when
he thought hey you know maybe I could
actually do this it's possible Obama
would have run with that Harry Reid's
encouragement but it's possible he would
not address so that's a huge legacy the
other thing I think he leaves behind is
he plays by his own rules he doesn't
care what the president's he cares what
his constituents think he cares what the
Democratic caucus thought but otherwise
in early care and there were times like
for instance in the 2012 campaign when
he started to put out word the mitt
romney hadn't paid federal taxes and
claimed he had this great source where
ever anyone else in politics would have
bent to the criticism of how dare you go
on the Senate floor and engage in this
he didn't care and I think I think there
a lot of politicians today who would
help themselves and their causes if they
were more like Harry Reid and just said
look I'm gonna do what I want to do I
don't care about the well in this weird
he seemed like an hour guy at a kind of
archaic guy if you ever got to meet him
you would see him he seemed older than
his years in some ways but in that
moment he understood modern media
dynamics as well or better than anyone
that you could actually pay in the
middle of a presidential campaign you
could make baseless unfounded
accusations and pay no price but consume
a lot of media cycles distract Mitt
Romney and be a real thorn in the side
he was old school in terms of using his
power for his state you know Yucca
Mountain would never have never would be
built as long as Harry Reid was a
senator he did not want nuclear waste
shipped from all over the country to his
state he may happen now it's a huge loss
for the state and he was able to within
his own state keep support amongst
Republicans the Republican establishment
a lot of them supported him part of how
he got reelected because he did stuff
for his constituents and that's a big
part of the job a big part of his legacy
absolutely a whole bunch of pork